[Musique]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 le journal voici les
titres des étudiants du lycée franco
allemand de buc et du lycée
international de sèvres ont suivi une
présentation des institutions de l'union
européenne hier après midi
objectif préparer le débat du parlement
européen des lycées en 2017 qui se
tiendra vendredi 19 mai à l'assemblée
nationale notre portrait de la semaine
est dédiée à thomas et estelle jouvenot
les dirigeants des saveurs du comptoir
un couple de torréfacteurs installé à
voisins le bretonneux y qui fête ses 10
ans cette année
et puis deux nouvelles serres ont été
montés sur la parcelle de la croix ou
cuir à magny les hameaux samedi dernier
l'initiative a mobilisé 40 bénévoles
le bac c'est dans un mois dernière ligne
droite des révisions avant la première
épreuve de philosophie elle se déroule
le 15 juin pour le bac général et
technologique alors comment bien se
préparer à l'épreuve
voici les conseils d'alexis masson
professeur de philosophie pour la
philosophie c'est votre l'élu les thèmes
et sujets abordés sont très vastes donc
c'est que certains coeurs des fiches est
un atout après il ne faut pas tomber
dans l'excès inverse de faire des fiches
qui sont parfois beaucoup trop précise
donc en général ce que je conseille
c'est de faire des fiches plutôt large
sur les termes qui sont régulièrement
abordés comme le désir la société
boehner qui sont les thèmes qui
reviennent c'est souvent et certains
lycéens ou d'autres échéances à venir
comme préparer le débat du parlement
européen des lycées en 2017
il se tiendra le 19 mai prochain à
l'assemblée nationale pour être prêt le
jour j des jeunes du lycée franco
allemand de buc et du lycée
international deux sèvres ont suivi une
présentation des institutions de l'union
européenne
un reportage de nicolas landry et
mélinda coréen est des lycéens le lundi
des eurodéputés le vendredi ses élèves
du lycée franco allemand de buc
participeront dans quelques jours à une
simulation de débat à l'assemblée
nationale
avec pour vaste thématique est l'avenir
de l'union européenne un moyen
d'intéresser les plus jeunes au sujet du
vieux continent de connaître un petit
peu les enjeux européens et puis
d'apprendre à agacer tension européenne
et aussi de se questionner sur les
enjeux européens d'aujourd'hui pour le
moment en place à la formation et la
pédagogie conseil de l'union européenne
commission européenne ou encore
parlement européen
à chaque fois chaque institution on a
des propositions pour les modifier c'est
ça qu'on va leur montrer pour leur
permettre des pistes de réflexion pour
leurs débats de vendredi
elle n'aura fait que représentera le
parti populaire européen marc buisson
l'alliance des démocrates et des
libéraux ils seront près de 40 lycéens
venant de cinq établissements à défendre
leurs convictions ils ne reprennent ce
une bonne chose parce que ça apporte
beaucoup de chercheurs pointent culturel
donc grâce le sur le plan économique les
soutiens financiers mais je pense qu'on
a on est bloqué au niveau des traités
qui on a beaucoup de ce trou il ya une
prolifération des traités et du coup ça
a mené à une politique finalement
complètement bloquée au niveau de toutes
les chaînes parlementaires
je suis plutôt défendre une position
vraiment ces derniers justement avec une
constitution
les cinq prochaines années s'annoncent
des années extrêmement charnière on va
dire pour pouvoir renforcer integralis
non européenne
le débat de ce vendredi 19 mai pourrait
permettre la promulgation d'une loi une
loi votée elle parlait vrai eurodéputés
doit-on pouvoir choisir sa fin de vie
l'association pour le droit à mourir
dans la dignité relance le débat elle
tenait hier à verser une conférence
publique avec le changement de
gouvernement l'association espère voir
évoluer la loi
un reportage d'anne laure languir aversa
et quelques dizaines de personnes sont
venues écouter les mots de jean luc
romero le président de l'association
pour le droit à mourir dans la dignité
en france l'euthanasie reste illégal
mais la dernière loi clé leonetti
autorise l'arrêt des traitements et une
mise sous sédation profonde du patient
une avancée encore insuffisantes pour
jean luc romero
on vous endort vous n'avez jamais vous
réveiller on arrête de vous alimentez on
arrête de vous hydrater vous pouvez
mettre trois semaines à mourir alors que
nous
demandons que la personne puisse partir
en quelques secondes
entouré des siens après l'avoir dé
revoir plutôt que d'avoir ce longtemps
d'agonie dont on ne voit pas du tout le
sens sur ce dossier les législateurs se
montre plus prudente la population selon
un sondage 80 % des français seraient
favorables à l'euthanasie dans la
nouvelle loi clé leonetti les volontés
des patients écrite au préalable doivent
être respectées par les médecins mais là
encore l'association veut aller plus
loin
les directives anticipées sont possibles
dans notre pays le seul problème c'est
qu'elles ne sont pas obligatoires pour
les médecins et c'est pour ça que nous
on se bat pour que ce que vous écriviez
quand vous avez en plus toute la
connaissance de cause toute la capacité
ce soit obligatoire et que les médecins
soient obligés de de faire ce que vous
demandez beaucoup de personnes dans
l'assemblée sont concernés par ces
questions
l'une d'elles a tenu à remercier le
président pour son soutien dans une
affaire personnelle
non on attend du nouveau gouvernement
qui changent enfin de logique pour
l'instant on a fait des lois sur les
devoirs des médecins vers toutes ces
lois ont été confiés à des médecins
c'est pas une affaire médicale c'est une
affaire citoyenne
on veut une loi qui place enfin celui
qui meurt au centre de la décision pas
sûr que les choses bougent le candidat
emmanuel macron s'était prononcé en
faveur du maintien de la législation
actuelle le café c'est la deuxième
boisson la plus consommée au monde après
l'eau certains le consomment via les
fameuses dosettes d'autres en brasserie
ou encore grâce aux torréfacteur ils
sont un peu moins d'une dizaine dans les
yvelines parmi eux les saveurs des
comptoirs à voisins le bretonneux
l'histoire d'un couple thomas estelle et
d'un commerce qui fête cette année ses
10 ans portrait de nicolas kirilow vite
et moi mon objectif qu'il arrêtait ça
serait pas qu'au moment où au moment où
café correspond plus à ce que j'attends
et que les clients d'attendre c'est un
savoir-faire que thomas pratique tous
les matins depuis dix ans la
torréfaction un processus qui demande
précision et concentration de 15 à 20
minutes de cuisson selon le grain et la
saveur souhaité le café pendant cette
crise on va subir plusieurs processus
il va prendre
ses arômes bien entendu il va perdre du
poids parce que l'eau va s'évaporer et
il va aussi prendre en volume et d'asie
en amérique du sud le voyage dans les
saveurs est ici permanent 15 café sont
ainsi torréfié avec des mélanges maison
et une volonté éco-responsable
indissociable des choix des stèles et
thomas on part d'un principe très simple
c'est que si on veut quelque chose de
qualité il faut qu'on ait les
plantations et les fermes qui qu'ils
soient investis dans l'or dans leurs
productions et cet investissement va se
retrouver aussi haut niveau au niveau de
l'écologie et au niveau de l'humain
preuve de la qualité des produits servis
thomas a reçu en 2010 le prix du
meilleur torréfacteur de france
seulement quatre ans après l'ouverture
du magasin
un titre qui récompense aussi
l'investissement total d'un couple
l'objectif c'était de deux secrétaires
nouveau nouveau choix de vie à deux
de s'investir dans un projet que
comportaient tous les deux et et
d'évoluer dans un univers et dans un
métier qui nous plaisait qui ne faisait
que le matin en se levant pour aller
travailler on avait plus plus envie plus
de plaisir que que les précédents
mythique qu'on faisait qui correspondait
peut-être moins à nauman aux envies à
nos profils sans formation et sans
connaissance particulière du café en
2006 ils sont en 2010 est connu et
reconnu de la vie locale
ils vendent aussi près de 120 références
doté pour leur dixième saison les
torréfacteurs vie sinon à propose une
série d'animations ce jour la vente de
sacs à café au profit d'une ong trouver
les numéros de lots l'origine le poids
met donc on est un petit peu c'est
l'équivalent un peu de la bouteille de
vin en france voilà alors on fait pas de
magie on a des petits commerçants leurs
propres limites notamment d'un des
contraintes économiques c'est évident
mais voilà ça ça apporte
à beaucoup de bonheur dans le quotidien
d'une petite boutique beaucoup de
bonheur aussi pour les clients du
magasin tous séduits par la démarche éco
responsable de l'animation
je trouve ça très très généreux de leur
parc et surtout c'est vrai que c'est ni
démontré un esprit d'ouverture
je trouve le concept génial sans plus
adaptée par rapport à leur activité donc
voilà je viens de faire une demi heure
de route pour pour venir chercher des
sacs pour continuer à fêter leur passion
du café estelle et thomas proposeront
des animations jusqu'en juillet autour
du biscuit et de l'apéritif deux
thématiques comme le café à consommer
avec sagesse et on prend la direction de
manille vermot samedi dernier une
quarantaine de bénévoles ont monté de
nouvelles serres sur la parcelle de la
croix au bruit cette initiative doit
permettre à maresché de s'installer
reportage de stéphane servant robert
pires est maraîcher à magny les hameaux
il a pu s'installer depuis deux ans et
demi grâce à la mairie qui lui loue des
terres car il fait partie du réseau amap
un réseau de production locale et
d'entre aide
ainsi il peut vendre la totalité de sa
production et en vivre robert aime la
diversité des légumes qu'ils cultivent
des légumes souvent différent en
fonction de la saison
il me reste encore quelques légumes de
divers la scène qui se termine
des pommes de terre des poireaux des
courges et sur justement les légumes de
printemps avoir des fours avait des
choux pointu il a eu besoin d'installer
de nouvelles serres dernièrement les
terres ont en effet besoin de respirer
il faut organiser la rotation des
cultures en fait si vous mettez de même
légume de fou de deux années de suite au
même endroit eh ben vous vous épuisez la
terre petit à petit le légume bas
ne poussera pas aussi bien qu'il est
temps de préparer la livraison vers la
commune pour 18 euros vous récupérez
chaque semaine des légumes sans
connaître la quantité ni la variété
souvent des légumes méconnu dont il faut
ensuite imaginé des recettes
effectivement passe son temps sur
internet a essayé de trouver
qu'est-ce qu'on va cuisiner ce soir
parce qu'on ne sait pas ce que c'est les
adhérents se retrouvent comme
aujourd'hui pour la distribution mais il
s'agit aussi d'un geste militant
consommer local des légumes sont
proposés mais pas seulement
tous les mercredis à livraison des
légumes de robert donc on a installé sur
la commune depuis mai
l'année dernière un mercredi sur deux et
en plus les livraisons de volailles
fromages pains farines ce modèle porté
par la volonté d'adhérents et d'élus
existe dans d'autres communes pour des
consommateurs soucieux de connaître
l'origine des aliments qui souhaitent
privilégier une production locale et les
températures étaient estivale
aujourd'hui elle atteignait en tout 26
degrés nous sommes allés à votre
rencontre et qui à lui seul est j'aime
bien être dehors voilà peu de temps
toute la journée ça serait l'idéal peut
pas rester enfermé qu un temps pareil
avec toute la pluie qu'on a eu on
profite des cons et en dehors des
possédés lors cette ville il fait beau
on va manger en terrasse
ça met de bonne humeur qu'est ce que
vous voulez boire l'apéro au mojito
alors ré et en 38 sec bois temps ça nous
permet de faire un petit break dans la
journée on profite du beau temps ça fait
du bien indispensable le nom mais ça
fait plaisir quoi car on a besoin du
beau temps profiter du temps comme ça
c'est ça fait du bien pour profiter de
la terrasse et
c'est très maniable et demain les
températures estivales continua devrait
atteindre 28 degrés profitez bien de
cette journée car c'est la dernière
météo france annonce des journées
pluvieuses à partir de jeudi des
températures en dessous des moyennes de
saison avec 16 degrés c'est la fin de ce
7 8 le journal merci de nous avoir
suivis et surtout bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]